you
hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar maximizing sensitivity
the impact of BSI CMOS and image
processing and scientific imaging I'm
Judy O'Rourke of lab routes and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes to leading a scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by photo metrics
founded in 1978 photo metrics is an
established industry leader in designing
award-winning high performance
scientific cameras photo metrics
maintains its leadership role with the
release of prime the first and only s
CMOS camera to provide built-in
computational intelligence for image
restoration and more recently the
prime95 be the first scientific CMOS
camera to offer 95 percent quantum
efficiency photo metrics also offers
comprehensive om support more
information is available on the
company's website at photo metrics comm
so let's get started this webinar has
been approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits you can
post questions through the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the Q&A box which will open
when you click the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window questions will be answered after
the presentation to enlarge the slide
window click on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
button found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at lower left I now present
today's speaker Ratched Mahindra the
product manager for life science
research cameras and photo metrics
ratchet has been intimately involved
with the development of scientific grade
BSI CMOS cameras that have made a
significant impact in single molecule
detection and super resolution
microscopy his experience in managing
the design intricacies of award-winning
CMOS and CCD cameras has given him a
unique
perspective on emerging light detection
technologies and their expected impact
on life science microscopy rachet
Mahindra will now begin his presentation
hi everyone
um welcome we'll be going through
cameras and really how to maximize the
sensitivity and get the most out of the
cameras and the products that are
available for imaging and so to give you
just a quick background behind photo
metrics we are have a digital camera
company founded in 1978 so we are coming
up to a year number forty next year
we're based in Tucson Arizona which is
really known for its impact in astronomy
and that's actually where photometric
started out with imaging and it turns
out that there's a lot of similarities
and commonalities between imaging in the
sky and imaging within cells they're
both low-light situations where the
camera performance and the sensitivity
is a very key factor of the performance
and the requirements and over the years
we've done a wide range of cameras and
leverage many different sensor
technologies see CDs EMC CDs were there
you know basically the most uh sensitive
cameras around and now over the last
probably seven to eight years of
scientific grade CMOS cameras probably
three about 2010 or so see CDs were the
preferred imaging technologies and this
was definitely reflected by all the
cameras that were available at the time
and not just from photo metrics but from
the majority of scientific imaging
camera companies at the time be the way
that CCD has worked they were fantastic
at low-light imaging they provided the
performance that was necessary but there
was a bit of a trade-off that you had to
make if you pick the sort of three main
performance requirements of a per camera
those being the sensitivity of the
camera the resolution and the speed CCD
cameras required you to effectively
two of those three the third being the
the trade-off that you had to make
simply if you wanted a very fast a very
sensitive camera that typically meant
you needed very large pixels and not
very many of them so that you could
image you know with a lot of sensitivity
and very quickly and they provided
enough versatility for a large variety
of these applications especially for
cellular imaging but as technology
progresses things get better and in 2009
2010's CMOS technology arrived and s
CMOS just stands for scientific CMOS and
F CMOS cameras or the sensors in these
cameras effectively removed the
requirement of having to make a
trade-off they gave you a significant
improvement in the performance and they
gave you the ability to have both
resolute or serious without both all
three resolution speed and sensitivity
in in one camera package and it
effectively made it very very simple
you went from a CCD camera the most
popular being about one point four
megapixel to the most popular CMOS
camera being four megapixels you know
almost three to four times more pixels
you went from 10 frames a second to a
hundred frames a second you're now 10
times faster you know the time
resolution the jerry-built achieved just
was an order of magnitude better and the
noise levels dropped significantly
allowing you to detect dimmer and dimmer
signals that the the one sort of
limitation that was always was still in
place was that the sensitivity was only
slightly improved yes you didn't have to
choose between you know resolution speed
sensitivity because they match the CEO
was significantly better that EMC CDs or
picking these large pixel very high
efficiency very sensitive cameras we're
still preferred for applications where
you need to duck sensitivity where you
were imaging very very dim samples and
modules and to give you a basic
comparison
the improvement that you were able to
achieve when you went from CCD s to s
CMOS cameras here we have an agro light
slide that's basically a pattern that
you can just a slide that you can put on
your microscope an image this pattern
that gives you a quantitative comparison
of the difference in sensitivity and the
way that we've done the comparisons
throughout the slide deck we were using
a caring twin cam with a 50/50 light
splitter with both types of cameras in
the comparison and being used so that
each camera was getting 50% of the
available light off of a microscope and
as you can see here the F CMOS camera is
just providing you know better contrast
better signal-to-noise than the ccd
cameras were able to offer one of the
interesting things when I was analyzing
this this images the maximum signal
measured by both of the cameras was
effectively about the same but the big
difference being that because the noise
levels were lower would CMOS technology
you the result was a better looking in
it's better contrast better
signal-to-noise
until sensitivity please the the single
difference there was the same and so it
doesn't really take a CMOS technology
which offered significant improvements
to a point where you can use it for
extremely low light imaging and so since
2010 when a CMOS camera technology was
first introduced there have been
improvements that have been made over
the years to improve this sensitivity
and so one of the main factors of
sensitivity is simply how much light is
reaching the light-sensitive area of the
pixel and the impediment anything along
the way that either blocks the light or
reflects it away will reduce the
sensitivity or the ability of the pixel
to detect that light and so the first
one being fill factor this is simply how
much of the pixel area is sensitive to
light and you can see my very high-tech
image there that if you take that
circuitry area and you reduce it
optimize the two-dimensional design of
the pixel you can maximize this fill
factor reduce the area taken up by the
circuitry and you have more area to
detect the light and this first initial
step took a CMOS cameras from about a
fifty five to fifty percent fifty seven
percent quantum efficiency or
sensitivity and increased it to about
seventy two percent so it was it was
quite a quite a big increase there and
what we saw as chemical companies was a
big shift from these initial 55 percent
sensors to the new 72 percent sensors
now believe this was done is the
circuitry was made smaller by removing a
transistor so consider maybe I'll making
the design smaller it was more that
functionality was taken out and so the
55-percent sensors had global shutter
and the 72% since his only had rolling
shutter and initially at the time this
was a bit of a concern
because people worried about you know
moving artifacts and what not affecting
the image quality but when you have a
sensor that runs at a hundred frames a
second it was quickly demonstrated that
this really wasn't much of a concern and
so taking a 55 percent quantum
efficiency camera with the reduced or
with with a lower fill factor and
comparing it to me 72 percent there's uh
there's a definite increase of quality
that you're able to see in the image
called II here on the left side we have
the Q imaging optimist camera with over
55% a CMOS camera compared to the
primacy loss with the 72 percent sensor
and other than the obvious change in the
field of view the quality of the image
is better you're able to get better
contrast and overall about when
comparing the intensities there was
about a 25 percent increase in
sensitivity and so you know it clearly
demonstrated that improving fill factor
improving the two-dimensional area of
the pixel was having was having a
benefit in sensitivity and well
device people who develop technology and
continue to push the performance of our
farmers and detectors the questions
really armed to continue to improve this
EMC city needs a you know greater than
90% to 95% efficiency and it's sort of
the standard in terms of where you want
to get to their sensitivity and so the
the next step of improvement really came
with trying to optimize the the
three-dimensional efficiency of a pixel
and being able to detect the light and
so we've a lot of the metal wiring and
other structures of the sensor that
might also potentially get in the way of
being able to detect light most sensors
use what we call micro lenses lenses
that are very small that cover the pixel
that are used to angle the light towards
the photodiode to effectively angle the
light around any of being the
impediments or blockages towards being
able to detect the light and by
improving this micro lensing design by
removing the gaps between them you're
able to increase this efficiency and
angle more of the light towards that
photodiode around you know the metal
wiring and structures in in the pixel
and this allowed the quantum efficiency
to take another jump from about 70% to
82% but interestingly enough while when
when you did when we did the standard
quantum efficiency tests what we found
is that yes you know we were able to
measure this 82% this 10% increase in
sensitivity but when it came to
microscopes microscopy where light tends
to be very parallel though the
improvements are actually quite minimal
there's less you know light at the EPI
periphery is a pixel that can be
reflected down to the photodiode and so
when we do the side-by-side comparison
what we found is that there is less of
an improvement we're talking two to
three percent if that when comparing the
72% s CMOS camera
- the 82% a CMOS camera with the
improved micro lensing and so it was
really nice to be able to say hey look
we've taken of the big jump in
sensitivity but the unfortunate
situation was simply that the real-world
results didn't quite present this this
improvement that that many people
expected and so the quest of the Chiefs
or this near-perfect sensor continued
and as we continue to use that E&C
shinee's as our you know near-perfect
sensitivity sensor they're able to
achieve this by using backside
illumination or back illumination and
they've been doing this since 2001 or so
and the question has always been
especially once a CMOS cameras came out
is why don't we do the same thing to
CMOS cameras why don't we backside
illuminate these sensors to get a
significant significant increase in
sensitivity and so back thinning or
backside illuminating a CMOS sensor was
by no means a novel idea but even even
if it was the common common sense thing
to ask it's still difficult to do and
still a challenge and so it wasn't until
you know probably about last year so
that a backside illuminated CMOS sensor
was was available and
it's very dependent on well as the pixel
design because you effectively have to
design the pixel upside down place all
the circuitry behind the photodiode
behind the light-sensitive surface and
what this allows you to do is you get a
hundred percent fill factor and there's
no angular dependencies which were which
limited us when we went from the input
which we which limited us would be
improved micro lensing and so you are
able to achieve this near-perfect 95
percent quantum efficiency now the Nexus
was the fish company that came out with
or I should say the only company today
to come out with a back illuminated CMOS
camera the prime95 be and there's the
quantum efficiency Kurt there which you
can see gives you a significant increase
in sensitivity across you know though
the whole range of wavelengths there but
it's it's not just as simple as now that
we've achieved 95 percent quantum
efficiency cameras are perfect and
there's no room for improvement what it
really allows you to see his cameras are
exceptionally sensitive and this offers
a significant amount of advantages you
can use lower excitation on your samples
you know there's less loss of photo
toxicity or you could maintain them get
better signal-to-noise because you have
this 95 percent efficiency of signal
detection you can lower your exposure
timer and yet capture faster dynamic
events that be the sort of other part of
it that people don't realize as much as
simply now that the cameras are so
sensitive you know 95% with EMC CDs 95%
with back backside illuminated CMOS
cameras and you know 80% with with the
front illuminated if you will s CMOS
cameras it allows you to focus more on
your experimental requirements and the
optical setups and adjust and tweak your
detector requirements around the spatial
resolution that you require
or what is the typical magnification
that I use and how do I maximize my
sensitivity at at that magnification and
so let's do a comparison between these
three technologies and EMC Sydney the
prime95 B and the front illuminated s
CMOS cameras and so you'll see you know
the quantum efficiency and there's
differences in the sensor but they're
all extremely sensitive in terms of
common efficiency they all had a very
low lead noise but all we know 67 when
between the second or faster but the
biggest difference between them but is
really that the pixel sizes are
different and this will have a big
impact on your optical setups your
detection capability the field assume
that you're able to image with with
these sensors and so everything that
this pixel size becomes so important and
especially towards sensitivity is think
think of them like buckets historically
we've always used this bucket brigade or
buckets to represent pixels and simply
the Biggers of the the bigger the bucket
the more signal or water or however you
want to describe it with whichever
analogy you would use the bigger the
pixel the more signal you are able to
detect well in that pixel and so what we
have here is just a comparison of the
pixel areas and so in that first table
they're comparing the comparison
extremely large pixel of an e/m CCD to
the large pixel if the prime95 B which
was which is an 11 micron pixel you'll
see that the the e/m CCD pixel is almost
just over twice as large as the 95 B
pixel and that simply means that if you
did a side-by-side comparison with all
optics and everything else being the
same the e/m CCD would come out as twice
as sensitive now that last column there
the sensitivity difference that's just
another calm that I added in to also
counter the difference in quantum
efficiency so if you look at the the
last table at the bottom where the
compare the prime95 b to the SC boss
camera you'll see that there's almost a
3x difference in pixel area but another
increase in sensitivity because we're
going from this 80% quantum efficiency
to 95% and so again if you did a
side-by-side comparison between the
prime95 b and the front illuminated CMOS
cameras you'd see about you know three
to three and a half times more
sensitivity with the 1098 b now when you
actually give a comparison the numbers
bear out the differences that you see oh
we had a customer here actually in
tucson arizona where where we go to test
our camera sometimes that were imaging
these I believe they're neurons and mice
and they were trying to detect these
spines growing and they have all three
count all three types of technologies
which is why this made made made this so
interesting they had an EMC CD they had
the 82% s CMOS and we showed up with the
prime95 beat to do a comparison and what
they told us is simply
we tried the emc CD and while it was
extremely sensitive and we had fantastic
signal-to-noise the pixels were just too
large for us to be able to properly
resolve these spines growing on these
dendritic spines as they grew so we
switched to the 82% s CMOS which was at
that time the next best option and while
where they were now able to get the
resolution to see them growing they
weren't able to get the signal-to-noise
that they needed and the reason it was
so important to them was the photo
toxicity to these cells when one of the
cells started to to die the whole slide
was effectively no longer useful and so
with the prime95 B with an 11 micron
pixel where you're getting no three and
a half times more light per pixel at
that same magnification they were able
to find this perfect balance between the
sensitivity and the resolution and
that's one of the key parts is being
able to take the camera technology
available to you and optimizing it
specifically for your your experimental
setup and so doing that side-by-side
comparison just with the other cell that
we have here because I use this
throughout the slide to give you a
comparison point you do see a
significant increase in sensitivity and
contrast part of this being due to the
quantum efficiency but is a
significantly larger part being due to
the fact that the pixel size is larger
Dec cannot just have giant pixels all
right that's where EMC she's kind of
become limiting because you're spatially
subsampling you're missing the finer
features that customer was not able to
image the the dendritic spines as they
they grew you need to be able to resolve
these features and so the the
magnification and the optics that you
use are are a key part of the
experimental setup and something that
you definitely have to consider when
when choosing a camera for or for your
experiments and so typically for
microscopy we defined the maximized
spatial resolution that you can achieve
by by by the MAF your objective that
also depending on the magnification and
the pixel size of the the sensor or
camera that you're using you can tailor
the camera to your optical setup and so
looking at that table there with a 60 X
magnification the pixel size of an SD
mask camera happens to be almost the
perfect size to maximize your resolution
at 60 X and similarly the 95 B becomes
the perfect camera for the hundred X
magnification and then EMC CDs worked
out 450 X and so if we take these three
sensor technologies at the appropriate
magnification for them to to maximize
this spatial resolution how do they then
compare and so pixel sensitivity of
Micra shows that the difference in pixel
size is very very negligible at the
appropriate magnifications and so they
have a very small effect in your overall
sensitivity and what you find is that
the quantum efficiency the the actual
efficiency of the pixel regardless of
the pixel area is having a significantly
larger impact on your sensitivity
to kind of give you this comparison when
you compare the e/m CCD camera at a
hundred and fifty X to the prime95 B at
100 X now they're both at micro sampling
they're maximizing their spatial
resolution resolution you can see that
the sensitivity between them is
effectively the same now there are other
downsides to EMCC technology you know
the amplification of shot noise and
whatnot that the prime95 beat doesn't
have and so overall it makes it you end
up getting better signal-to-noise ratio
but because you're also using
a hundred X magnification compared to UM
in 50x the actual image that you capture
with the prime95 B is that and you're
getting a significantly larger field of
view while maintaining the same
resolution and while maintaining the
sensitivity and so it really becomes key
to to design your experimental setup and
optics and choosing your camera based
off of you know your requirements if
you're typically at a hundred X the
prime95 B becomes the the the best
option to choose the you know the
natural question then becomes what is
what is the best option for me at sixty
X because you've just told me that
quantum efficiency plays a key role in
in maximizing my sensitivity at the
right magnification and he also told me
that the 80% sensor performs much more
like the 70% sensor though the micro
lenses aren't having as big of an effect
and the answer to that is really just
you have to have a small pixel
back-illuminated camera and for the
prime BSI which which we announced about
a month and a half ago provides you this
a 95 percent back illuminated backside
illuminated CMOS camera with effectively
the same pixel size and resolution and
performance as the current generation I
should say now previous generation of s
CMOS cameras and so the prime BSI is
able to offer you that 100% fill factor
and 95% efficiency and becomes optimized
specifically for the 60 X magnification
and similarly to the other curve showing
the increase in sensitivity from the
prime95 be the prime psi which is the
the dark blue curve in this image shows
you that you're getting a significant
improvement and sensitivity across a
large you know wavelength range there's
an interesting little bump on the movie
which people can be interest
didn't alien
and you do need a shave Kenosha between
the 82% camera and the backside
illuminated prime BSI with the 95%
quantum efficiency you are now able to
achieve the same spatial resolution at
60 X you are able to not have to trade
off on that field of view but you are
also about 10 to 10 to 20% more
sensitive ah 30 percent if you expect
the 80 % camera to behave much more
similarly to be 70 % front illuminated
cameras and so the prime BSI becomes a
drop-in replacement for all of the
existing s CMOS cameras out there
because your optical design doesn't have
to change experiment experimental setup
that you may have already optimized for
that pixel size or if you consistently
use a 60 X objective it this camera
becomes a drop-in replacement to give
you a 30% improvement in your overall
sensitivity and so now when designing
your your system or your experiment the
the efficiency or the sensitivity of the
camera isn't really your biggest concern
anymore because you have three options
that provide you this near-perfect 95%
quantum efficiency so
Chace to continuously improve our
cameras and their performance and we've
effectively got to a point where we have
near-perfect sensitivity for a variety
of cameras for a variety of
magnifications and we we've effectively
allowed you to remove that as a
significant concern if you will from
your experimental setup so the next
question really becomes what now and as
camera manufacturers what can we deal
with 10 a technology to allow you to get
more out of it and part of it is simply
we know the image data coming into the
camera and we have all of that
information available to us and we can
leverage that information to extract as
much information out of it as possible
the first example being prime enhance
this is a denoising algorithm that
evaluates the image data as it's coming
in and based on that data it can reduce
the impacts of shot noise increase the
quality and clarity of your acquired
images and the result in the result of
being your signal-to-noise ratio
increases by a factor of 3 to 5 now I
will clearly state where this is
processing your data this is done real
time on the camera it's a feature that
you can enable or disable so it's not
something that you have to use but as
soon as you mention it we're processing
data there there's there are a few
concerns that that do come up the first
one being simply what are you doing to
my data how is this affecting the
quantitative nature are the features I'm
using going to be blurred is this just
like a medium filter and the answers to
that are simply a it's quantitative and
it's preserving the intensities while
just removing the shot noise or
variation along that measurement it's an
algorithm that will maintain the finer
features of biological samples and
lastly we didn't want this algorithm to
be a black box image data goes in black
box does some work and then improve
signal-to-noise image comes out it's a
published algorithm that was invented at
the INRI riaa Institute and tested out
with in collaboration with the Institute
Curie in France and is they published
algorithm with the title of the
publication being you know literally
denoising fluorescence microscopy image
sequences and let's all speak for
themselves really we have this
comparison here where we take a camera
we turn the feature off and we took the
image and then we turn the feature on
without changing anything
and we we took that measurement and the
graphs that you see there are the two
measurements laid upon each other we
took the intensities we converted them
to photo electrons or the electrons
detected by the sensor and what you can
see is that the mean intensity the
average intensity is detected are
maintained and it is primarily the
fluctuations or the noise along that
measurement that is reduced and so you
are able to significantly increase the
quality of your images increase the
contrast that's available to you but yes
we are also processing the data and so
there will be a reduction in your frame
rate the sensors are capable themselves
without any processing of being able to
do a hundred frames a second full frame
with this feature enabled you're limited
to about 20 to 30 frames a second which
generally we find is it's still plenty
fast enough for imaging live cells and
so we've seen this you know a lot of
improvements of imaging quality while
using this prime enhancer denoising
algorithm and even in ways that we
didn't expect initially we found that
people have attempted to use prime
enhance with super resolution microscopy
as well and found that you're able to
increase the your localization precision
if you acquire your data with this
feature turned on low and I should say
there's indications of this and we do
have a
a reference or a paper that is available
on our website at folio metrics comm if
you do have no more questions about this
but talking about utilization microscopy
and when you're talking about 95 percent
sensitive cameras and the single
molecule imaging or super resolution
microscopy becomes an obvious place to
to consider these cameras and so we've
also implemented a feature called prime
locate which is now on its second
iteration or second generation and prime
locate is effectively an
application-specific compression
algorithm so it's it's an intelligent
compression algorithm specifically for
super resolution microscopy with super
resolution where you're imaging you know
many thousands of frames of single
molecules the background is typically
not information that is required you
really just want these single molecule
intensities and if you're able to
evaluate the image data for what is
background and what is a single molecule
what kind okay will allow you to do is
transfer only the single molecule data
to the computer so the way that it does
this is simply it assumes that the
background is static anything in the
background that's not moving it takes a
set number of frames that is
continuously updating and it removes
that from the processing requirement and
so now that you've taken this static
background away you're looking at only
the dynamic events and these dynamic
events it will evaluate to see if
they're dynamic single molecule like
events and if they meet that criteria
the single
molecule a region around the single
molecule was transferred to the computer
so the goal for us was simply don't do
the localization because everyone
chooses or prefers to use their own
algorithm so we transferred the single
molecule with all of its own original
intensities to the computer without any
of the background information and we
found that we get about a 70 to 80 85
percent compression of the data allowing
you to a save the amount save the space
on on your computers and and secondly it
also increases the localization and
processing speed the localization speed
because there's less filtering that's
required the background is zero
everywhere except for where the single
molecules were and so you're able to
achieve a higher efficiency overall and
reduce the amount of time that it takes
to localize these you know ten to twenty
to sixty thousand frames stacks and so
as we as we've been demonstrating prime
locate and using it for or for single
molecule are sorry for super resolution
microscopy there's the natural question
that followed is if you're able to find
these single molecules and separate them
from the background and only transfer
those can you use this same
implementation or the same framework to
be able to track the molecules as they
move across the frame and you know that
got us thinking and that got us working
on real-time particle tracking on the
camera and so similarly to locate the
camera evaluates what is background what
is static what is not moving and then
we'll evaluate the image data for single
molecule like particles and track those
across the frame now the key difference
here between locate and the particle
tracking is that the goal is not
compression the goal is not to help you
with your data management the goal is to
allow you to do your experiment and
while the experiment is running being
able to evaluate things like am I
getting the expected number of particles
in a frame
are they moving at a rate that I expect
or are they moving at all how far have
they traveled and and it gives you the
ability to evaluate your experiment as
it's running as opposed to most of the
time with particle tracking where you
need to acquire the data have your stack
of data and then go analyze and
post-process it later and so anytime
that you have to run an experiment
analyze the results and realize I need
to rerun this experiment that that can
be a big time sink and so being able to
evaluate this data as it's happening and
making sure that you're getting the
activity as expected can save you a
significant amount of time now I also
mention that the goal of this is not
compression and what I meant by that is
where we transferred the whole frame the
whole image so the frame data will
include will include the background it
won't be zeroed out it will include all
of the particles but the information
transferred with the frame will also
include you know with each particle
it'll include the historical information
of the particle and all of this
information is transferred so that when
you do eventually do the post-processing
for the particle tracking all of the
information that would have been
available to previously is still there
and so it becomes it really becomes a
tool to allow you to ensure that yes my
experiment is running as expected and
then still go do the analysis as you
would have otherwise that increasing the
the efficacy if your experiment by
allowing you to say I don't need to go
rerun this data at a much later time now
similarly here we didn't want this
tracking algorithm to be a bit of a
black box and so it's based off of this
paper that that's at the bottom of the
slide there written by small Z reading
about feature point tracking so if it's
primarily a two-dimensional tracking
algorithm
and so the bowl really becomes with
these cameras that are so sensitive with
a 95 percent efficiency that have been
tailored and are optimized for your
experimental setups to to be able to
give you more information from the from
the information available to the camera
itself to help you with the results to
either a you know give you better image
quality to help you with the large data
management and so the Prem B acai the
prime95 B and then EMC TV cameras become
the the right cameras to use for the
magnification of your experimental setup
for the experiment that you're running
and it just makes it simpler because
it's less about the camera because the
cameras are the cameras are do nearly
perfectly sensitive but it becomes more
about focusing on the rest of the
experiment the field of view the
resolution the optics most importantly
at the biology right that that that
tends to be the largest challenge and
the cameras really are just there to
help with the other aspects you know as
I venture in improve the data quality of
the management and application-specific
tools help you get more efficacy better
efficiency out of the experiments help
you save time and get you better results
simultaneously and so that's that's a
bit of the direction in early data
metrics is going with our cameras it's
not just about introducing the most
sensitive cameras available and you know
taking 30 to 40 percent improvement
across across the board first
compared to our CMOS cameras but also to
help you with the experiments and to
make to make the actual process of the
experiment better and so with that I'd
like to thank you hopefully this was a
informative webinar and if you have any
questions feel free to email me I do you
think we have some questions here so you
can go through those yes thank you
ratchet for your presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
questions simply type them in the Q&A
box found like clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window rachet Mahindra will
answer as many questions as time permits
and the first question is can you
explain more on the impact of pixel size
larger pixel size heads higher capacity
larger dynamic range but not necessarily
more sensitive or less noisy correct so
that's generally correct yes the larger
the pixel size the larger B typically
the capacity for that pixel to be able
to hold higher levels of signal so yes
you do get more dynamic range out of it
then it won't as you mentioned it won't
affect the noise of that pixel that will
really come down to the design if that
specific pixel and whether it will
necessarily be more sensitive or not
again will come down to whether it is a
back illuminated pixel or not to give
you a bit of a comparison point the
front illuminated s CMOS cameras with
the same pixel size 6.5 micron had a
full well or pixel capacity of about
30,000 electrons the same pixel size 6.5
micron with the backside illuminated
sensor on the prime BSI has a full level
of about 40 to 45 thousand so you're
seeing not just an improvement of
sensitivity but about a 30% increase in
the well capacity even with the same
pixel size so while the pixel size will
have an impact on you know the the
dynamic range and the amount of signal
you're able to measure much if it also
comes down to the ability of the the
design of the pixel and how much pixel
well it is designed for how does the BSI
compare to the sensitivity of an AM CCD
when the BSI is bend to X so I
this is one of the questions that I had
a feeling would come up um because
they're both backside illuminated pixels
with the hundred percent fill factor it
would compare very very similarly now
the advantages that the BSI apprendi si
or the bins two by two pixel would have
is simply that when bin it has a it
becomes a 13 micron pixels so 13 microns
by 13 microns while an e/m CCD pixel is
16 microns also so sorry what I mean to
say the efcc pixel would still have a
bit of advantage there just because it's
a larger pixel area the EMC CD will also
have the advantage because the minimum
noise level tends to be less than one
electron so you would be able to detect
dimmer signals with the higher image
quality but anything more than about 10
photons to about 10 photons or so you
would get better better result with a
bins 2 by 2 pixel from the backside
illuminated apparently aside the only
challenge there becomes with the optics
that you're using at a hundred X you
would be spatially subsampled and you
would need a higher magnification to
that there to kind of counteract that
but yes that's definitely an option but
generally we find that when optimizing
for the optics the 95b tends to be the
better option for 100x while and unbend
Prem DSi tends to be better for 60 X
often the last year or so of having both
you know EMC season the prime95 B is
what we found is that the results of the
prime 95 d when compared to EMC CD
chemists tends to be significantly
better and we found that a large portion
of the user base is switching from EMC
CDs to the prime95 be the larger pixel
backside illuminated camera
the next person says very good
presentation very informative and nice
presentation thank you and their
question is is the camera application
limited to microscopy can you comment on
the application to low lighting to low
lighting imaging surveillance autonomous
cars long distance imaging telescope yes
so if it's a minute - microscopy
definitely not right it really becomes
what is required for daily application
and what with the necessary performance
requirements are and so can you use it
for surveillance and autonomous cars and
long distance it yes the the challenge
will become if you take no long distance
imaging or telescopes for example they
typically tend to use much longer
exposure times and CMOS technology isn't
really conducive to that but if you need
a high-speed acquisition with that
maximum sensitivity for any of these
applications it becomes a viable
solution
if there are no more questions I would
like to once again thank Ratchet
Mahindra for his presentation do you
have any final comments I think
everything was great thank you for the
questions and again if there are any
other questions you know feel free to
get in touch with us through being
through the website and thank you very
much thank you I'd also like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions we would
like to thank our sponsor photometric
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the seee button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
June 2018 lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event I just want to add
that we have another person who
commented agreed fantastic presentation
thank you
so until next time goodbye